what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be talking about my fitness goals
and a comment that i got on the last
video when i weighed myself
so um i don't know if this is just
you know simps or whatever but i've
gotten this before so that's why i
decided to make a video on it
um so in the last video i weighed myself
and i was 189 pounds and the comment
that i got a lot
was that i don't look that heavy um and
then i posted a picture
just like in my community page and a lot
of people said you don't have 20 pounds
to lose that's my goal
and um what's the second thing they said
oh and i needed to build muscle and this
is why you shouldn't take fitness
advice from the internet because um you
guys are very wrong
so the funny thing is i was a college
athlete i was a three sport college
athlete
and i'm 24 so that really wasn't that
long ago like i graduated
two three years ago um so that just
doesn't go away so i'm actually pretty
strong like the last time i maxed on
deadlift
um i did 250 last time i maxed on bench
i was five pounds away from a plate like
i
am strong and you can see this i'm gonna
put it on the screen
but um in this chart i got and it's
funny because
at 185 i weigh more than like an average
guy
should weigh um this i took back in
november so i was a little bit thinner
before i got a boyfriend
um um but even at that like if i lost if
i was 180 i would have been in the
healthy weight and i still would have
weighed more than
the average guy so a lot of times you
really can't tell how much
someone weighs just by looking at them
um and yeah these are just my numbers i
was just going to show it with you guys
i'm sure they're a little different now
but this was
like six months ago so they can't be
crazy different
but yeah um
i'm excited to go through this journey
with you guys though i am going to be
skinny